では よろしくお願いします
まあ今日から今日の講演は
仏教には苦行がないっていうテーマになります
で 苦行はないということで
正しく修行すればそれは幸福になるっていうことで
仏道の修行そのものも大変幸福な楽しい道なんですね
だからそれはもう何回も言ってあげなくちゃいけなくなっていますよ
なぜかというと とにかく仏教に悪口を言うということは
世間の常識になっていて
人間っていうのは幸福になるのはものすごく嫉妬しているんですね
ですから とにかく仏教にだけ悪口を
腐った道だったらとことん褒めてやるんですね
だから世の中でそういうことはありますから
まず調べようともしないで
仏教なんかは現代的じゃない
苦しいんだ そんなのはやる
やれませんとか何とか言うんですよ
だから他宗教の人々が悪口を言うのは
それはどうしようもないんです
それはそう構いません
そちら宗教信仰は違いますからね
それに怒る必要はないんです
仏教ではなくて 他の宗教を信仰している人々は
仏教に悪口言ったっても
それはニコニコと聞いてあげた方がいいんです
問題はこの仏教を学ぶ人々なんですよ
学んで私たちに俺が知っているぞと教える人々が
もう断言的に仏教を壊しているんですよ
だから一番仏教を知らないといえば
学者ではなく キリスト教の人々もそれなりに知っているんです
なんと言おうが イスラムの人々はね
特に自分の国に住んでいるイスラムの人々に聞いてみると
結構淡々と仏教の大体の概論だけはちゃんと知っている
それには批判もしません
それに代わって学者に聞いてみると
もうものすごい邪言ばっかりなんですね
それでこの 特に大乗仏教系の学者の方々は
ブッダのことを研究しながら
ブッダではなくて お釈迦様が悟りする悟る以前やった苦行
そればっかり徹底的にハイライトしようとしているんです
で 釈尊にしたっても この研究する本人と大した差がないんだと
四苦八苦でこうではないか
ああではないかと 暗闇で
手取り足取りでもいろいろ探していた
迷いに迷った人であると平気で言うんですね
だからまあ昔は私はすごくそういうことを言うと腹が立ちましたけど
はっきり言うんで あなた方迷って迷ってるんだからといってね
他の人もそんな風に言うなよと
だから一番仏教を知らないのは学者の仏教学者の方々だから
自分とよりすごいレベル低い人間にしたがるんですよ
だって お釈迦様が東大出ていないでしょうに
まだ精神的に病気もないでしょう
だから自分よりは 大事なのは後作られた経典群
パーリ聖典のことを言うんですよ
ではなく 苦行の生き方であると
パーリ聖典ではそんなことは苦行こそ都合やと
私は迷いに迷いに迷っていたんだよと
今も四苦八苦で頑張っているんだよとは言ってないんです
四至こうなんですね パーリ経典になってくると
私に右に出るものはないんだよと
いるならば出てこいと
私言うことに何か異論があったら出てこいと
そうやって公でオープンチャレンジで時代も入れてないんですよ
現代インドの人の間でとかね
将来的にでも出てこいというふうにオープンチャレンジで語ってますから
だからその経典は関係ないんだと
とにかくパーリ経典はもう間違っていると
その証拠として大乗経典を取り上げるんです
だからまあちんぷんかんぷんもいいところなんですよ
どう見てもその学者も言うんですよ
この経典とか文献の歴史の流れを言うと
どうせパーリ経典は古い方に入っちゃうし
大乗経典というのは紀元前だからね
紀元 １世紀の後から書き出したものであって
ブッダとは年も離れていますよ
で そこを証拠に出すんですね
出してパーリ教ってそれはダメです
だからあんた方後で書いたもんでしょうと
だからどこまで人を騙すのかというね
大乗経典を正当化するためには
悟り以前の宗教と生き方が必要なんです
だからポイントがありますよ
大乗経典に書かれているのは仏教ではなくて
一神教でヒンドゥ教なんです
あの紀元期 西暦 １年  １世紀で
あの非論がインドで現れたんですよ
あのアドヴァイタ・ヴェーダンタというヴェーダンタ哲学がありまして
特にこのシャンカラという哲学者が
あの当時のあらゆる宗教を勉強して
非論というものを作って
そこがヒンドゥ教に入れすけといたんです
まあヒンドゥ教につけたというよりも
あのブラフマという神様という概念は全部一つだと
一切一であるという哲学を作ったんです
それで他の宗教家がすごい困ったことになったんです
あの反論できなくて で
非論にしても そこの最初に非論を作ったのはナガラジュナなんです
それも仏教の人なんです
で そこはそのまま導入しちゃったんです
そういうわけで この大乗経典にあるのは
いろんな神々の話やらおとぎ話やら
人数の話やら 奇跡の話やら
超能力の話やら もう何でもかんでももう観音力で何でもなくなりますよとか
で そういうあの 例えば法華経
法華経 法華経のあの 何でしたっけ
観音盆あるでしょうに
だからまあ迷信も神秘主義ももう形而上学ももう嫌になるほどあるんです
だからそれはまあ密教的に
あのもうヴェーダ ヒンドゥー教そのものなんですよ
ただ だからそこは正しいというためには
ブッダが悟ってから語ったものは迷惑なんです
だからブッダの悟る前の生活だけあればいいんです
悟る前にブッダも一般のインド人としていろいろ勉強したり
学んだりしていたんだからね
いろんな先生たちを訪ねたりしていたことは事実ですから
それで十分だと 悟ってからこんなのはいいやと
だから学者さんがこの煩悩をなくすということは不可能であると
そこまで言うんですよ
どうやって言うんですかね
不可能ですと 煩悩っていうのは人間の本能でしょうと
それだったら自由な哲学者として私はこう思いますよと
このヨーロッパでもいろんな哲学者がいたでしょうに
そうやって哲学者として哲学として語ればいいんですけど
そう語らない 仏教学者として語るんですよ
それも学術的には間違いなんです
哲学者として自由に語るのは大丈夫です
そういうわけで このブッダも苦行を説いたものやと言って
それから初期仏教というか
テーラワーダ仏教はブッダのパーリ経典を中心にして学んでいるんだから
そんなのは苦行で現代人にはできっこはないんだと
だから一信教でよろしいやと
他力でというふうなことにするんです
だいたい日本の学者はみんなまあくたびれた時は浄土真宗になります
もう研究するときは何研究したっても
くたびれてボケたところでも浄土真宗なんです
パーリ経典に苦行の記録を残されているのは
それが無駄でしたと言うためです
だからパーリ経典に当然苦行の話があります
お釈迦様が年というのは計算して６年になりますけど
はっきり私は６年間も苦行しましたとは書いてないんですけど
菩薩でいた時は悟る前に未熟な時はこんなこともやってましたと
わざと未熟な時と書き換えているんです
ボーディサッテイラサトアナビサンブッド
私は何もわからなくて
未熟な時はこのような苦行してみましたと ６
年もしているのは お釈迦様は 28歳ですね
19歳で出家して  35歳で悟ったんだから
そこは６年になるんです
はっきりもう６年間苦行したかということは
これもあまり正確な記録はありません
なのにお釈迦様は自分が悟る以前のこと
家でいた時やったこととか
たまたま語ってはいます
それは正当化するためではなくて
こんなダメなこともやっていたんだよという意味なんですね
ただ批判するのは仏教的ではありません
ただ単にお釈迦様は試しもしないで物事は批判しません
調べようともしないで
だからお釈迦様は何か批判したならば
そのものをちゃんと知り尽くしているんです
だから仏教徒によく言うんですよ
我々出家する人々にも
ブッダに説かれたものはそのまま認めなさいと
わからなくても これはしょうがないんだよと
納得いかなくても それはあなたの頭が悪いんであって
ブッダが悪いんじゃないんだよと
そのうちわかりますよと
要は お釈迦様は知り尽くして語っているんだから
シッダート菩薩は最初に苦行で苦しみをなくす方法を見つかると速即なさいました
シッダート王子様 王子は王子ではない
菩薩ですね 悟る前の状況は菩薩というんですね
お釈迦様の名前はパーリ語でシッダートというんですね
それで世の中みんな苦行で
みんなといってもインドで出家した人々はみんな苦行でなんとかなるんではないかと思っていたんです
苦行苦行をしたくない人は在家でいればいいんです
でも在家でいたっても
何の精神的な優れた境地にも達することはできない
それははっきりしている
で ですから出家したんです
バラモン人は在家でいたんです
だからバラモン人は在家で神にお祈りするだけで十分だと
自分たちが生まれつき聖職者だよと
バラモンカーストの人々は
だから修行する必要はないんだよと
だからそちらバラモン人の生活ぶりを見ると
ものすごく贅沢に溺れて
インチキやるは詐欺をやらは人の財産を奪うは
あらゆることをやっているんですね
ですから それはもう宗教の道じゃないと思った人々は出家したんです
バラモン人の中でも こんなのは
その生活は嫌だと これは何の精神性もないんだと思って出家したんですよ
そこで バラモン人であろうが一般の人々であろうか
出家したグループはやっぱり贅沢では何も得られませんと思っていたんですね
そこまでは自然の流れで
それで菩薩もああ そう言うんだから
自分も出家したんだから
次にある道は苦行することなんですね
自分も出家の仲間だから
それでお釈迦様も悟る前に不完全な時
未熟な時は じゃあもしかすると苦行で聖なる境地に達するのではないかと思って挑戦したんです
苦行を惨憺する 誰にもできないほど厳しい苦行に挑戦なさいました
それでお釈迦様の違うところは
もう何やっても第一になるまでやるんです
誰かに何か言われるところを残しません
何やってもいつでも一人者なんです
すごいこの負けず嫌いなんです
それぐらい能力もありましたし
子供の頃 勉強する時でも
教えるためにはインド一流のバラモン人を呼ばれたんだからね
一番トップクラスのエリートたちを
でももう 2 3ヶ月間で学んで終わっちゃったんです
で 先生たちにはどうすることもできないんですよ
昔 暗記で教えるんだから
先生は暗記でサーっと言っちゃうと
お釈迦様覚えちゃうんですね
子供の頃 覚えてるだけじゃなくて
その暗記したものの意味も解説も分析もできるんです
分析もできて 先生にでは私はこういう風に理解しましたけど
いかがでしょうかと逆に言うんで発表するんです
先生もどうしようもその通りだと
では 次のテキストに行きましょうと
でお釈迦様は言うんですよ
先生が あの 口を動かしただけで
おったぱはたまというのは唇を動かす
言っただけで 自分がテーラワーダンチャジャナーミニャーナワーダンチャ
私はそれを確定して ホンホンネまで本意でしたっけ
そこまで知ってますよと
ニャーナワーダっていうのは
その教えを元に基づいて自分の思考を持っていくこと
自分の哲学を作ること
そこまでできたんだよと
先生からガチャガチャ怒られながらも怒鳴りっぱなしで
もう何回も繰り返しながら勉強することはなかったんです
だから子供の頃からもうもう
まあ想像を絶する能力なんですよ
まあそれもそれで長い長い間ね
菩薩として修行して 修行して
徳を積んで積んで積んできたんだから
いかなる生命もブッダに比較できません
徳で 能力で だから悟る以前は自分が未熟だと言いましたけど
人間から見れば何の未熟さもなかったんです
そういうわけで 一旦苦行に挑戦した時も
誰にもできないところまでやってしまったんです
みんな苦行は惨憺するんだけど
出家の方々はお釈迦様ほどは実践しなかったんです
そんな勇気はなかったんです
あのジャイナ教のジャイナ教は未だに苦行の宗教なんですけど
一生苦行はしません 日にち決めて
じゃあ一年間 あるいは半年
あるいは三ヶ月間とか
あるいは一週間とか決めて厳しい苦行をするんです
それからまたちょこっと楽に
贅沢はしませんだけど
まあ楽に普通に生きていて
それからまたまた修行に入らなくちゃということで
またもう一回苦行に挑戦するんですね
お釈迦様はそれじゃなくてぶっつづけて苦行をやってみたんです
だから この三回も仮死状態で倒れちゃったんです
そこで 1週間断食行をやっているとき
1週間一回ぐらい この梅干しぐらいの大きさの
食べ物は食べる  1週間一回
それであの痩せて あのパキスタンにあるあの仏像ありますね
骨ばらけの その行でそうなってしまったんです
皮膚と骸骨だけで で それでもう倒れちゃったんですよ
意識もなくなって 呼吸も止まって
ずっと見守っていた神々はやっぱり亡くなったんだと
お釈迦様は悟ることができなかったと
悲しいなと 期待していたんだけどと言って
父親に報告したんだそうです
息子は亡くなったと ただ
父親が神に伝えているのに
何を聞いたんですか？と神に聞いたんです
うちの子は目的に達したんですか？と言ったら
これは誠に残念なことでできなかったんだよと
ああそう だったらうちの息子は死には死にはしませんよと
あの子は自分の目的に達するんだよと
出て行ってくださいと
悟り開いたぞ 死ぬはずがないんだと
だから父親は父親でものすごい自分の息子のことを知っていて
何者かとよく知っていたんです
だからそこは研究の参考にしちゃうと
日本の研究者の論文は壊れますからね
全部使わない 作った話やと言うんです
作った話と言いながら
スッタニパータにあるものは一番古いんだというんです
今私が言うこともスッタニパータにありますけど
ナーラカ長老の作品として
はい そこでお釈迦様が考えたのは
この完全接触なんですね
完全接触するぞと思ったところで
どうなることかといったら
もう確実に死ぬ それで確実に死ぬことを決めても
その前に悟らなかったら意味がないんですね
だから苦行しても 死ぬということは避けなくちゃいけないんですね
それは論理的なんですよ
だったらいきなり自殺しちゃえば早いでしょうに
だから 苦行で心を清らかにするならば
ギリギリまで苦行しても
死ぬ寸前で止められ 止めなくちゃいけないんです
それをお釈迦様はよく明確にわかっていたんです
ですから 完全断食というどうしようかなということで考えて
やっぱり完全断食するぞと決めたところで
神々が来て これだったらあんた死ぬだけですよと
それはどういう話かわかりませんだけど
しかし 我々はもうあなたが悟るまで待っているんだよと
人類のためになるんだからね
ですから それはやめてください
あなたが完全断食するならば
私たちはあなた方に栄養をあげます
体に入れますよと 言われるとお釈迦様はいかに正直かというと
そこ書かれているところは
もし神々が体の皮膚の穴から栄養を入れちゃうと
これは神々の栄養だから感染なものでしょうし
体は全くすがすがしがる立派な体に体格に戻るんです
1週間足らずで しかし
お釈迦様は何も口に入れていないということは話にならないんですね
というと これだったらこの連中は苦行してくれないんだということで
完全断食はやめたんです
それでもやってみたら
やがてこれは意味がないんだと決めたんです
決めたところもこうおっしゃってますよ
私はこの世の中で苦行を説く語る人々の苦行の中で
私は全部やっている 私ほど苦行した人々はインドではいません
だから誰よりもトップクラスで苦行しても
私には精神的な上達は一つもなかったんだと
ただ心は汚れませんよと
それはお釈迦様と珍しくはなかったんです
現代の社会での断食したり
いろんな厳しい滝行をやったりすると
欲なんか消えちゃいますよ
朝三時起きて険しい山を走り
足で登ると もうものすごい勢いで般若心経を唱えながらね
またすごい勢いで下りてくると
欲なんか生まれるとこじゃないでしょうに
まあ元気な人にはできるんだけどね
そんなのはお釈迦様にとっては何の意味もないんです
当たり前の論理なんですよ
例えばひどい病気に倒れちゃって
もう痛みで苦しみでもうもう頭が朦朧としている時は
別品の看護婦さんが来て
いかがでしょうか 体触ったっても
もう何も感じませんよ
可愛い人やとかね その時欲が生まれるどころか
男か女かとももう区別するぐらいの頭動かないんですよ
だから俺が結構心ができているんだよと決めていいんですかね
だから 六年間の苦行でお釈迦様の心には微塵も汚れの思考が現れなかったということは
当たり前のことで 別にどうったことはないんだと
それでまあそれは認めますけど
上達したこともないんだと
心は だから無意味だと
わかって 自分が子供頃出家する以前もたまたま瞑想を試していたんですよ
その時もいとも簡単に禅定状態に入っていたんです
時々休みがあったら瞑想してみたら
もう禅定に入れるんです
そこでアーララからムッドからブッダという仙人二人がいて
その二人にも尋ねて行ったんだ
その二人からもより高いレベルのお釈迦様
再起で子供頃経験した瞑想よりも
ものすごい高いレベルの瞑想法も教えてもらって
それも一日二日で達していたんです
だからそちら辺に道があるんだよと
心は次元を破って破っていくんだから
その心次元を破っていく道を選ばなくちゃいけないということで
お釈迦様はまあそれからゆっくりご飯も召し上がって
体力を戻して で 最後にスジャータという女性のね
から 牛乳を入れて炊いたご飯をね
召し上がって まあ一番重い栄養たっぷりなものを食べましたから
これでもう十分やと 瞑想してみますと
今度は悟らないでは立ち上がれませんと
座って立ったならばもう悟っている
そのままだったら死んでしまいますよという覚悟で
いわゆる死の覚悟がなければうまくいかないということもあります
で 悟り開きましたからね
こういうところは説明いたしました
仮死状態になるまで修行苦行してみたんです
苦行 企業者たちに何の文句も言えないほど苦行してから
これは無駄だという結論に達したのです
だから いい加減苦行を無駄だと言ったわけじゃないんです
やってみて 試してみて
ダメだと言ってるんだから
なんで素直に現代人にそれを認めることができないんですかね
それでももっと苦行すれば悟るのではないかと
苦行しない人には言える
だから 現代の研究者みたいに苦行の一かけらもしないでね
もうもう酒に溺れて生活しているんだから
こういう人々にはもうちょこっとあの人に苦行してならば悟るはずではなかったとかは屁理屈は言えますよ
次 釈尊は中道を実践して悟りを開きました
それで苦行は効果なしという意見は決定的になったんです
もっと苦行すれば悟れる
悟れたんではないかと言っても意味がない
お釈迦様はすでに悟っているんだから
中道で もし苦行をやめてからもお釈迦様は悟らなかったならば
あんたもったいないでしょう
もうあと一年間ぐらい苦行しなければ悟るはずではなかったんではないでしょうかと
そんなことを言えるはずでしたけど
言えないはずなんです
お釈迦様は中道で悟ったんです
だから 学者の方々はあえて悟ったことは否定するんです
ただのもう一人の人間として研究するんです
それはヨーロッパの影響で
ヨーロッパの人々いうことをそのまま真に受けることがかっこいいみたいですから
まあそちらはもうキリスト教は正当化するための他宗教の研究でしたから
もう悟るということは認めるはずがないでしょうに
お釈迦様の超能力なんか認めるはずがないでしょうに
超能力なんかはイエス様にあるのは当たり前なんですけど
神の子でもない人間にはあるはずがないとかね
思うのは そちらの方々の場合は納得できます
しかし 自由な研究する人々はなんでその話に乗るのかと
自分たちが乗った時点でキリスト教は正当の宗教であるということは間接的に認めているんだということは忘れているんです
だからブッダを褒める場合は
何かイエス様の聖書でも似ているところがないのかを探すんです
何も似ているところはないんですけど
というわけで 第 1 セクションで言ったのは
苦行は無意味ということは決定的なんです
なぜならば 苦行で毎日で悟って見せたんです
お釈迦様以外 誰も悟ってなかったんです
それも経典にありますよ
書いて コウサロ様からでお釈迦様に失踪するんで
あなた若いし まだ髪の毛黒いし
なのにあなたは完全者だよと
完全智者だよと ブッダだよと
悟りに達しているんだよと堂々と言っているんだよと
しかし あなたよりは倍年上の一生修行している古老人の仙人たちは一人も言ってないんだよと
私が悟ったんだよ と なんであなたそんなこと言ってるんだよと
いうと お釈迦様ちゃんと答えるんです
まあ世の中で唯一私だけですよと
悟りに達したのは そういうわけで
苦行では解脱できない
それが結論です 経典に苦行の記録があるのは
その無意味さを語るためです
正当化する目的はありません
次のセクションに行きます
これからテーラワーダ仏教のパーリ経典の仏教に入ります
批判のセクションが終わりました
苦行は大人気 肉体的な行なので見ればわかるんですね
苦行っていうのは 他人に自分の修行を発表しやすい
私はこんなことをやっているんだ
こんなことをやっているんだと
肉体のことだからね 発表しやすいんです
苦行しない贅沢好きな俗世間には
その厳しさがよくわかる
そこで俗世間の一般の人々は修行しないし
贅沢しているし そういう人々から見れば気持ちよくわかりますよ
自分が美味しいご飯を食べているのに
ものすごいまずいご飯をほんのちょっとしか食べていない人はかわいそうだなとかね
なんて苦労しているんでしょうかとかね
この気持ち感じやすいんですよ
したがって 社会から高い評価が得られるんです
供養者が 社会に褒められますからね
尊敬されますから これが落とし穴なんですよ
結局は俗人に褒めてもらいたくてやっていることなんですよ
お釈迦様もそれに悪口言ってますよ
愚か者に褒められても
あんなのは褒めになりませんよと
無知な人にあんたすごい頭がいいんだよと言われたっても
何にも褒めにもなりません
だから 一般人に認めても認めなくてもどうでもいいんです
理性のある人に 賢者に認められることが一番正しいんですよ
しかし 苦行者は確実に一般人に認められる
褒められる 尊敬される道を歩んでいますね
自分にもよく頑張っていると自画自賛できる
苦行する人には 行儀式
儀礼などは基本的に大人気ですから
場所がないんだから文章を切っちゃったんです
まあですから この行儀式
儀礼 祈祷 あれこれやとあるものはかなり人気なんです
日本の寺っていうのはあまり信者さんが行きませんだけど
成田山なら 毎日ものすごいんですよ
集まる人々は 朝五時からいるんです
なぜか知ってますか？ 1 日 5回
イスラム教と同じ護摩供養をやっているんです
はい ですから苦行は大人気ですよ
次に苦行の意味 一般的な意味
キリスト教の場合 遠い昔
ある人が犯した罪を償う目的は基本的になります
キリスト教の苦行っていうのは
こんな知らない古のある人が何か罪を犯したんですよ
あの野郎と言いたいですよ
あの野郎が犯した罪に関係ない人が苦行しなくちゃいけないんですよ
で キリスト様が その苦行を完了したんですけどね
しかし 生徒たちは軽くその真似をするんです
だから神父さんもまあ軽くその苦行をしてみるんですよ
修行をやっている神父さんにはモンと言うんですよ
ファーザーとか言わない
あの そういう修行道場もありまして
で 世間の人々も時々お祭りとしてやったりする
フィリピンの人々も このイエス様のこの十字架に打たれたその祭りをね
あのすごい自分の体を痛めながらやるんですよ
自分で石を持ってこの胸に投げる
叩くんですよ 血が出るまで叩きながら
行列で神を讃嘆しながら行く
それも苦行ですけど イエス様の受難の行の真似ですね
その気持ちわかってもらいたくて
本当は無意味なんです
キリスト教でもイエス様がもう馬鹿を見たんだから
他の人々はやる必要ないということになってます
どう見ても屁理屈だからね
関係ない どれ 誰かがやった罪に
なんで関係ない人が受難しなくちゃいけないんですかね
そんな屁理屈は何なんですかね
なんで神にはそれぐらい論理性ないんですかね
自分には何でもできるでしょうに
ヒンドゥー教 ジャイナ教では
自分が過去で犯した罪を償うために行うんです
そこら辺は一応マジマジなんですよ
自分が過去で犯した罪をね
神が犯した罪ではないんです
自分が過去で犯した罪を償うために苦行に挑戦するんです
それもある程度で論理的なんです
ブッダには批判できないはずなんです
しかし ブッダがそれを論理的に批判するんです
この中部経典で あの ある経典なんですけど
ジャイナのお坊さんたちがお釈迦様が住んでいるそばで
ところで一生懸命苦行をしているんです
それで托鉢に出たお坊さんたちは
よくこれを見られますよ
そうすると お互い一緒にほぼほぼ一緒に生活しているんだから
でも生き方は違うし 宗教違うし
だからお坊さん お釈迦様の弟子たちはもう普通にご飯食べて楽にいるし
だからもうなんでこんなに苦行するのかと聞いたところで
あなた方はね 贅沢ばっかりしてね
悟れませんよ そんなものでは
でも我々の師匠様が過去に過去で業を犯したんだから
その業を苦行でなくさなくちゃいけないんだよと
過去の業を それから新しい業を作らないでくれと
そうなってくると 業がチャラになりますよと
チャラではなくてゼロになりますよと
すごい数学的でしょ 過去の業を償って償って消す
新しい業は作らない そうすると 0 になるでしょうに
貯金は それで解脱に達しますよと
言うと お坊さんたちにしたってもう論理的でしょうに
反論できなかったんです
困ったもんだなと しっかり言ってるんだよと
言っても まあ自分たちがブッダの弟子たちだから
お釈迦様に言ったんですね
こういうことになりましたと
だから相手の考え方を認めることもしないで
否定することもしないで
黙って帰りましたと お釈迦様がそうということで
その人々のところに行くんです
で 同じことを聞くんです
なんであなた方は そんなに苦行をしているんでしょうかというと
同じ答えが出てきたんです
それで出てきたのは 我々の師匠が全知全能で
過去現在未来を常に知っていて
こういうふうに解かれたんだよと
だから我々は真面目に過去の業を滅び滅ぼして
新しい業をしないことにしているんだと
よくわかりましたと ではあなた方に聞きますけど
今どの程度で過去の業を滅ぼしているんでしょうかと
どれぐらい量は知ってますかと
これは知りませんと ではどれぐらい残っていますかと
苦行で燃やす業は あ これぐらいあるんだよと
それは知ってますかと
それも知りませんよと
その知りませんと お釈迦様にそういう質問されたところで
先生は全知全能であるということにもうぶつけたんです
私は知らなくても 我々の師匠様が知ってるんではないかって
けど お釈迦様 それはただの信仰でしょ
信仰っていうのは当たり外れ五分五分だと
もしかすると全知全能ではないかもしれませんし
もしかすると全知全能かもしれませんし
信仰ではダメですよと
しかし 私に見えるのは
あんた方は過去世で強盗をやったり
泥棒をやったり 女を犯したり
ものすごい罪を犯していた人々ではないのかと
だって人間で軽く生きられる人生で生まれても
あなた方はわざと寝ないで体をいじめているんだから
過去世で相当な悪人ではなかったんじゃないかと言って
もう帰っちゃったんです
だからジャイナ教で言っている個人が犯した罪を苦行で燃やすべきだというところは微妙に論理的ですけど
よく見るとこの量知らないんですよね
過去でどれぐらい業を犯したかっていう
量は知らないんですよ
で 過去の場合はある一定の時間で突然現象が現れたという有限論を語る人々もいましたし
いえ 過去を遡ったら無限だよという無限論を語った人々もいたんですよ
だから過去は有限であると言っても
無限であると言ったっても
過去はものすごい長いんですよ
だから過去はどれぐらいの量
業が我々持っているのかということをわからないんです
そういうわけだから その苦行の方法はもう論理的に成り立たないんだということをお釈迦様は説いたんです
また 神の疑似体験 神秘体験
解脱する目的で行う場合もある
これはあのジャイナ教
ヒンドゥ教に限らず 他の宗教でもありますよ
時々 あのキリスト教の方々にも個人的に聞いたことありますけど
この神の疑似体験したいんですね
イエス様の それで自分の信仰を固めるんですよ
それで苦行をしてみるんです
ヒンドゥー教でもいろんなところでこの苦行して
この神の疑似体験しようとしているんです
で 修行に修行してはいけませんという浄土真宗でも
お坊さんたちがそういう疑似体験しようではないかという厳しく苦行はします
たまたま念仏行といって飲まず食わず
もう 1ヶ月間ぐらいとか
もう立ったままで歩きながらやっているんです
そうすると体おかしくなりますから １
週間でも寝ないでいると
大変なことになりますよ
で 便所にも行ってはいかんのだから
やっぱり食べることもできないんですね
そうすると まあ必死で念仏を唱えているんだから
まあいろいろ現象が見える可能性はもうかなりあります
ものすごい可能性あります
それはただの現象で 脳のカラクリで別に正しいという証拠はないんです
それ場合も正しいかないかは五分五分なんです
本当に阿弥陀様がいて
見える姿を見せた可能性もあるし
阿弥陀様 阿弥陀様のことをあまりにも頭で念じているんだから
頭が作った幻想が現れた可能性
あります わかりません
それで別な反応してみると
本当に大慈悲の阿弥陀様がいるならば
そこまで真面目な人を苦しませる必要はありません
人は真面目で力説する
他人に念仏を教えたくて
あるお坊さんが やっぱり阿弥陀様のこと経験して思ったら
阿弥陀様が大慈悲だから現れて
じゃあ君 頑張ってください
私がちゃんといますよと言ってくれた方が
阿弥陀様の頭がいいということになりますけど
残念ながらそう現れてくれませんだから
阿弥陀様の頭も相当悪いんです
で 激しく死ぬ覚悟で苦行をしたところで現れるのであれば
これはもう明らかに幻覚ということになるんです
そういうことは イスラム教でもこういう神秘体験のために
例えば日本の方々は神秘体験が欲しくて苦行する場合もあるし
まあ解脱目的で修行する苦行する人々もいることはいるんです
しかし 目的はいくらかっこよくたっても
苦行は無意味です それはもう断言的に仏教で無意味だとと言っているんです
で インドではね あの 15 年一回かに 10 年一回かという大なる
ものすごいヒンドゥー教のお祭りがありますね
その時は山の中で 森の中で隠れている行者たちがみんなガンジス川のところに集まります
その時よく見られますよ
いろんな人が いろんな苦行をやっている人々が集まるんです
ほとんど見るとみんなこの神の疑似体験
ある人がよく思ってますけど
あのハヌマンの行をやってます
ハヌマンというのは猿なんです
で ハヌマンというのは猿で
猿も一応神様の使者なんですね
で これが宗教的なエピソードじゃなくて
この叙事というあの作品がありまして
マハーバーラタというただの作品ですよ
文学作品です 立派な作品ですけど
昔書かれたもので そちらにあるストーリーなんですよ
ラーマという王子が あのラーヴァナという夜叉たちと戦って
もう自分のお妃を取り戻すんですね
奪われちゃって で その時はこのランカという島に持っていかれたんだと
そこでまあこの戦うためにハヌマンという猿が猿軍隊と一緒に行ったんです
人間ではなくて で その中ボスがハヌマンと
ハヌマンというのは猿って意味なんです
とにかくハヌマンなんですよ
で 彼をだからラーマが神様にして
ハヌマンというのはヴィシュヌ神というふうに
後でヒンドゥー教で解説するんですよ
だから文学作品というのは信仰するもんじゃないんですけど
平気で文学作品を信仰しているんです
で それでこの私はテレビで見たんですけど
そのあるバラモンの行者がこのハヌマン行猿の行をやってます
体で灰色を全部塗って
ハヌマンハヌマンって特別な
今もインドで猿がいるんですよ
結構美しい猿ですけど
細く体細長くて 髪の毛は全部白で
顔だけ暗い黒いんですけどね
その形に体全部塗って座っても
一応人の前に出るんだから
ちょこっとふんどしみたいな
ほんのちょこっとのものは着ています
本当は一人でいる時は裸でいると思います
で 祭り出たんだから 何かちょこっと着て
それで座ってるんですね
それで信者さんたちが来て
拝むわ お布施をするわ
拝むわ お布施するわ しかし猿は喋れませんだから何も喋れません
それで金持ちの人とか来て
ちょっと高いお布施をして
いろいろ占って 自分の商売とかなんとかどうなるんでしょうかとか
家のこととか質問するんですよ
すると猿が手を一つ手を挙げて
あのヒンドゥの神々描いてる絵なんか見たらわかるけど
ハヌマン大体手一つを上げてるんです
手って一つ その通りに上げて猿の声するんですよ
どうかなんとかどうかとかね
私は子供の頃 ほとんど猿がいっぱいいたんだから
猿の真似ができます 今は恥ずかしいんですけど
で で そうやって猿の声出すんですよ
そうするとそばにいるんですよ
もうお世話係の人が その人は今はこの先生はこういうことを言いますとか
通訳してくれるんですね
えらい猿語をわかる人もいるんだな
これが今現代も信じているんだからね
ITのもうもう巨大国なんですけど
コンピューター技術になってくると敵わないんですよ
他の人々は ヒンドゥ人に
高度な数学を開発した国だからね
昔も すごい学問はもう学問は当たり前だと
食べるものよりも学問が必要だというふうな文化でしょうし
我々にもそういう文化ですから
そういうふうに教えられてあったし
食い物がなくても学問だけはやるもんだよと
あと 3時間で死にますよと言われたっても
あの 2時間5分55分まででも勉強しなさいよという文化ですからね
まとまって悪くはないんですけど
知識的には でも信仰になってくるともう最悪です
何の理屈もないんです
それで そこでもあの行者が何をやっているのかというと
この紙の疑似体験したくて
長い間ああいう猿行をやっているんですよ
だから悪口は言えませんだけど
やっぱりアホアホなんですよ
いくらなんでも かわいそうといえばかわいそうなんですね
それは一般的な苦行の世界
それから仏教的な苦行の見方
体と心は不可分離状態で機能しています
よく覚えてください 汚れるのは体ではなく心です
体は不浄なので綺麗にすることもできないし
またそれは気にする必要もありません
体はもともと肉体だから不浄なんですよ
これ 洗っても洗ってもあまり意味がないんですよ
だからと言って仏教は不潔でいいというわけでも言ってないし
人間にはもう気持ち悪くなるように生活してはいけないんですよ
渡辺君も今日いろいろ私にもかかってきたんですけど
まあ人間に気持ち悪いような格好をつけることは
社会に対して失礼な行動に当たりますから
ちゃんと格好つけて美しくいることは仏教は推薦するんです
それは自分の見えた見えのためでも
欲のためではなくて まあ普通の常識でみんなに気持ち悪くならないようにとしてあげることだから良いことなんです
と言っても そんなに体のことを真剣になる必要はないんです
適当でいいんです 常に心の状態は体に表れる
次の問題は この心の状態は体で表れるんです
逆に体の状態によって心の機能も変わるんです
それで体がおかしく 例えばだらしない服装を着て
もうあまり髪の毛も整理しないし
もう歯も特に磨きませんし
まあなんとか着てなんとか
でとかで生活すると 性格は心がすごくだらしなくなっちゃうんだと
体のことで心に影響を与えるんです
それで心の状況は体に表現する
心がだらしないんだったら
もう服装も何でもかんでもだらしなくなっちゃうんです
どちらかということはわからないんですよ
体と心の相互依存 依存を考えなくてはならない
ですから 仏教から見れば
我々は体と心の相互依存ということ
よく注意して考えておかなくちゃいけないんです
続きます それでちょこっと仏教の定義はそれで終わってしまって
また世論に入ります 肉体信仰
聞いたことがない単語でしょう
世の苦行は肉体信仰だと言えるものです
世の中にある苦行がありますし
あらゆる行がありますし
全部この肉体信仰なんですよ
肉体をいじめてなんとかなるんだと思っているんです
日本でもあります 修行と言えば結局は苦行なんですよ
肉体をなんとかすることなんですね
日本でよくあるのは滝行
なぜかというと 日本ではいっぱい滝がありますから
山もいっぱいありますから
インドではないんです
なんで日本でこの火山教やらないんですかね
火山もありますからね
ボコボコボコボコと あの硫酸あれ出てくるところ
あんなと飛び込んじゃったりとかね
いい苦行になる修行になると思いますけど
やっぱり修行の目的っていうのは死んだらあかんだからね
やっぱり死なない程度でちょこっとリミットしなくちゃあかんだから
滝行にしているでしょうね
清らかな体に清らかな魂が宿ると等がなくなってますが
思っているが 実は心は清らかであれば
体のことは心配するまでにはならないと言った方が正しいんです
これ逆なんですよ 本当は
あの日本でもこのヨガを教える先生たちはよくよくすごいことだと思って言ってますけどね
清らかな心に清らかな魂が宿るんだと
逆なんですよ 魂は清らかであれば
心も清らかで健康的であるというべきなんですけど
仏教は認めませんだからこういう文章にしたんです
魂のことを認めませんだからね
逆に言えば 清らかな心が宿っている体が清らかですよと
それが正しいんです 健康美容のためにヨガを始めて
うまくいかなくなったら精神にも興味を持つ人もいる
私のところにも来ますけどね
まあまず健康美容のためにヨガを始めても
あんまりヨガうまくいかないんですね
そうすると ヨガの先生から言えば
やっぱり精神のところも気をつけなくちゃと言ったって
向こうはあまりわからないんだから
じゃあもう異教徒の仏教からでも学ぼうかなと来てくるんですね
だからそう来たんだからで
そういう人々は精神に興味あるわけじゃないんです
ヨガうまくいきたいんですよ
なぜヨガうまくいっちゃうとすごい美しくて
もう痩せて健康でいられる
長生きできるんですよ
だから結局は肉体信仰なんです
その場合も肉体信仰は変わってないんです
そこで肉体信仰というのは現代人の信仰のことなんですよ
宗教は特別ではないんだけど
みんな肉体信仰なんですよ
どんなくだらない体に毒になるものでも
健康感があなたの健康を考えたとか １行書いておけば
パクパクと買って飲んだりするんです
しかし 法律に裁かれますから
これ飲んだら健康になりますよとは書きません
コレステロールの気になる方へ
と書いて なんとか飲み物
うまく騙すんですよ 嘘を言わないで文章はつなげておかないんです
カットしておくんです
それで肉体信仰の人っていうのは
まんまともうなせられます
ブッダの反論 ダンマパダ７０
月一回だけ草一枚を食べ物につけて舐めるだけの食事をする行者であっても
善良をする人の１６分の１の価値もありませんと
これはちょっとあんまりわかりやすい
美しい訳はできませんでしたけど
まあ私の文体はなかったんだから
この井原先生はちゃんと訳してますけどね
あの草 ある種類の草がありますよ
葉っぱがちょこっと長いんですけど
それ 例えばスープとか何とかってね
この草の葉っぱを入れる
入れて草だからあまり草に汁がつけないんですよ
しかし 一滴ぐらいは それは舐めて
はい 今日はごちそうさまでしたと
これって極限的な苦行でしょ
じゃあご飯も食べてくださいったってても
ご飯に草の葉っぱ入れたってご飯一粒もついてこないんだからね
そんなことをやっても
それも月一回 これ お釈迦様は無理も無理の無理を言ってるんです
人間にできるわけないんです
それぐらい苦行したっても
真理知ってる人の価値の 16 分の 1 にもなりませんよと
パーリ語は入れない 入れなかったんですけど
マセーマセークサゲーナ
バーローボンジョティボージャナ
サウェーサンカタダンマーノカランナッガナーガティソーラシンという芸なんです
それで 108 番目 徳を積む目的で
この世にある儀式 儀礼
行 施しなどは  1 年間行っても真理を知る人にただ礼をすることの 4 分の 1 にもなりませんと
例えば徳を積みたくて
1 年間毎日あらゆる宗教的な儀式
儀礼 あれこれとやっても
何の意味もないんだ 真理知っている人に礼をしてみなさいと
それの人にはもっと徳が積めますよと
それは 108 それで 107 番目
100 年間護摩供養をやるよりは
真理を知る人に一回布施をした方が価値が高い
だから成田さんは負けます
それもこの公じゃなくて
隠れて必死で真面目に護摩供をやる人のことを言っているんです
100 年間続けてやったっても大したことないんだよと
そんなに徳を積みたければ
真理を知った人にちょこっと一回だけ何か差し上げてみたらどうですかと
ナナッガチャリアナジャタナパンカ
ナーナーサカータンディラサーイカーワー
ラジョージャッラン ウックティカッパダーナン
ソーデーティマッタン
アヴィティンナカンカン
ラ行 これ頭髪行と書いてあるんですけど
これもうあまり日本語わからなかったんです
髪の毛を洗わないで 頭の上でターバンのように結んでおくんです
シーク教の人々はみんなこの
髪の毛をね 男はね もう長く伸ばして切れません
頭の真ん中で結んでおいて
ターバンつけるのその前に
でも体はすごい清潔すぎて
きちんと髪の毛をちゃんと洗うんです
ですから まあそれは汚いことではないんですけど
まあちっちゃな男の時でもちゃんとターバン巻いていると大人大人みたいに見えて可愛いんですけどね
で それはすごい綺麗ですよ
あの人は清潔すぎなんですよ
しかし インドであの髪の毛をただ上に持っていって結んで
そのまま それから髪の毛伸びても伸びてもそのままで
そこですごくきつくなっちゃいますよ
洗わないんだから  それはこのジャター行と言うんですね
このパーリ語でジャターっていうこと
結構いたんですよ この行者はジャティラと言うんですね
今はこのヒンドゥ教以外はないと思いますけど
でもインド旅に出たっても見つかりませんよ
このかなり田舎にというところに行かないとね
それから泥の中にいること
パンカー パンカーっていうのは体でずっと泥を塗って
いつでも泥のままでいるんです
ナーナーサカっていうのは殺食と書いたんですけど
本当は異色なんで変なものを食べる
もう人間は食べないもの
はっきり言えば人間の便も食べるんです
そちらはまだ栄養残ってるんだよと
それからとタンディラサイカワーっていうのは何でしたっけ？あ
じゃあ塵をかぶることですね
さあ そういうところで寝ていることですね
これはしゃがみ込んで動かないことなど
もう一つの苦行っていうのは
タンディラサイカっていうのは
これ殺食に入ります えーと
一つ行なんですよ もうしゃがんで座るんです
しゃがんで それからそのままでいるんです
動かない その姿勢は崩せません
動く人 動かなく動かなくちゃいけない時でも
その姿勢で動くんです
いくら苦しくても いくら体に健康に悪くなっても
骨がそのまま硬くなっても
やめない 続けてみるんです
しゃがんだままで 例えばもう半年間ぐらいいると骨がそのまま硬くなりますからね
もう手足が伸ばせ伸ばすことできなくなっちゃうんです
そういう苦行もあります
そんなことやっても清らかになりませんこと
お釈迦様は堂々と言うんです
心は清らかになりませんと
この心にある疑をなくさなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう風に  何の異論もできないようにお釈迦様は苦行を批判しています
いくらでも経典がありますけど
まあ適当なところでやめます
だからなんで肉体信仰という言葉を使ったかというと
この苦行も結局は肉体信仰ですからね
ナジャターヒナドッテーナナジャッチャーホーティブラフマノー
ヤンヒサッチャンチェダンマンチェソースーチソーチェブラフマノー
ダンパダの三百九十三
渡発業 家柄 生まれなどではバラモンにはなりません
真理と法 悟りと仏教を知ることですね
がある人こそ清らかであります
その人はバラモンバラモンでありますという
で ジャターっていうのはまた同じくあの特別な行をやっている人々
そんな特別な行やっても聖者にはなりませんよと
それからゴッタっていうのは
このバラモン人の間で
バラモン人であっても高い階級の人々は一番聖者ですよと
この家族は八人いたんだからね
ヴェーダ聖典を作った仙人たちの家柄
彼らがトップクラスの聖者たちとか思っていた
お釈迦そんなことはないんだよと
生まれは関係ない 家柄関係ない
そんな人はバラモンになりません
バラモンというのは聖者っていう意味で使っているんです
誰かが真理を経験して
ブッダの教え 真理を覚えて学んでいるならば
いわゆる理論と実践を兼ねているならば
その人が聖者ですよと
その人こそバラモンですよと
修行として形を取ること
行を行うことは否定してあります
そういうわけで 形で修行すること
行をやることは 仏教は何のことなく否定しています
ここで一つセクションは終わります